[Musique]
travailleuses travailleurs
oui je suis toujours dans le camp des
travailleurs et je suis malheureusement
la seule et y être vraiment chirac qui
prétendait réduire la fracture sociale
l'a laissé s'aggraver
la gauche au gouvernement depuis cinq
ans se flatte d'avoir réduit le chômage
le chômage a régressé un peu mais les
emplois précaires ou à temps partiel ont
augmenté bien plus la gauche n'a empêché
aucun licenciement collectif et les
promesses de reclassement n'ont presque
jamais été tenu pendant ces cinq ans les
plus riches se sont enrichis tandis que
le nombre de pauvres lui n'a cessé de
croître
aujourd'hui six millions de personnes
vivent sous le seuil officiel de
pauvreté c'est-à-dire ont un revenu
mensuel inférieur à 3400 francs et ses 9
millions qui doivent se contenter de
moins de 4200 francs pour survivre et je
ne parle pas que des chômeurs que des
retraités
je parle aussi des gens qui travaillent
qui sont salariés et qui sont pauvres
quand même ceux qui travaillent à temps
partiel à des horaires qu'on leur impose
ou non que des emplois précaires et ne
travaille qu'en fonction des missions
d'intérim qu'on leur offre et comment
oser dire que ceux qui gagnent le smic
ou même plus mène une vie heureuse et
confortable
les sondages qui me près 10% des voix
affole le camp du patronat et les hommes
politiques de droite ou de gauche à son
service en réalité ce qu'ils craignent
ce n'est pas moi c'est vous les
travailleurs ils ont peur que le vote du
21 avril confirment ces sondages et
montre que le monde du travail a été
vraiment trop trompés par la gauche et
qu'il est vraiment contre la droite
alors le 21 avril votez pour votre camp
le camp des travailleurs
[Musique]